Hey youtubers it's Charlie!
probably could be my Supergirl trailer video
they have a throw forward to all the characters
are bringing on in the next couple of episodes
of vertigo and episode one review I think
of actually going to reviews the first one
was not spoil re-because it was after the
league but up with some links and a description
for that you should have no idea what's going
on with the show what they're doing essentially
is the riffing on the Richard Donner Superman
films the first to Christopher Reeve films
so the tone the humor of the characters like
the energy just flows from that universe we
also need to address the other big green glowing
rock in the room I love that she's where she
wearing his green dress here will the show
have anything to do with any of the other
Warner Bros. DC shows currently and in season
one what they're saying is probably to probably
not like it needs to be a success all by itself
on CBS once is proven gets picked up for season
two then I think I'll talk about some like
crossovers when thinking about analysis because
the multi-versus a thing on the flash now
because we have all these different nurse
think of Supergirl is happening on a different
order from the other shows that's the simplest
way to explain why characters aren't talking
about other big powerful characters like of
Superman existed in the universe and the flash
is taking place in Earth one right now it
would be all Cisco talked about do you see
that freaking bad ass kryptonian alien to
being that shipped out of that other guy the
other week same goes for Batman multi-verse
theory of the DC universe but as you can see
in this trailer really like the characters
are there point of crossover with Supergirl
being the ship at a red tornado in this future
episode here he was created by Teal Morrow
who worked at star labs so it already you
can kinda see points of crossover star labs
is so much fun you there's so many crazy scientists
that is worked as star labs least of which
is Arthur light will be posting a flash video
after this were all talk about Doctor light
because the doctor like that they're actually
doing on the flash TV show is a female Doctor
light because Supergirl has the dual identity
she is the Clark Kent thingy launches Karen
Danvers who she is during the day she is carousel
rel Supergirl who she is what she's fighting
crime will be too big bad the first of which
and I'm just getting to spoilers from episode
one just careful if you haven't seen it yet
okay here we go the alien big bad is going
to be her on all the rock was her mother's
twin sister so that the way the way there
doing that is it someone from her family is
finding her that reminds her of her mother
you think you can see the drama there at that
and the Phantom zone which is where a lot
of the alien threats are going to be coming
from then you have human threads Maxwell Lord
is going to be the human big bad although
technically he's a metahuman because you superpowerful
we did meet them and episode one will probably
meet up pretty quickly though they they tend
to introduce the biggest characters in the
first couple of episodes and this'll be like
a 2122 episode run probably I don't know what
the exact episode counts going to be in season
one the next the character we see here is
a Lucy Lane a.k.a.
Superwoman played by Jenna Dewan Tatum that's
Channing Tatum's wife what I think is an end
up happening with her character is this going
to be like a lot of the characters they bring
on the flash so Lucy Lane just going to be
like regular Lucy Lane she's not getting it
superpowers anytime soon it just a fun Easter
egg for the comics that she became Superwoman
it is certain point but slowly and slowly
the going to build this out with Superman
and Superwoman characters from the comics
and they do get to use a lot of Superman characters
but most of Supergirl's biggest villains are
Superman villains to so course the TV shows
that we get to do a lot of that the really
big strike in Supergirl's favor is that because
it's on CBS it also has big network monies
they can they can do a lot crazier stuff on
screen the because the series has been in
production for little while they they've also
started to announce future characters that
we won't see first several episodes think
they just cast an official toyman even though
this character Supergirl's friend admittledy,
part of her and her inner circle is Winslow
Schott his father Winslow Schott senior will
be the actual toyman so it didn't sound like
at some point in the series they might give
him a villain Arkin helped turn in the toy
man to take the mantle from his father that's
always the fun promise of shows that it like
three or four seasons friends can become enemies
especially if they were villains in the comics
killer Frost is the best example that right
now Danielle Panabaker awesome on the flash
is Caitlin snow but she is going to be so
much fun when she turns into killer Frost
that's actually kind of a fun way to think
about Supergirl in imagine the flash like
the energy of the flash if it were told from
one of the female character's perspectives
if it was a show about killer Frost like Emmy
the for the flash is told from Barry's perspective
because he's the main character in the funny
thing is is that Supergirl and Barry have
ever relatively similar personalities devote
total geeks complete spasms so think about
how the flash season one cHanke from episode
one to episode 23 I really like the second
half that season was amazing like episode
and I the midseason finale of the flash last
year was one of the best episode of the TV
ever and then think about how awesome it's
gotten the season took us essentially the
same people are making Supergirl so think
about how much more awesome it's going to
get as we go along season definitely add Supergirl
to your TV rotation like your DC TV rotation
regardless of which show you watch first like
it airs the same time Gotham airs on Monday
nights so with you watch one of the other
first what's going to happen is is my videos
for Supergirl I won't post till like Thursdays
so you saw plenty time to catch up on it before
I post my video and what I meant to do is
I'll probably do like a trailer video for
the next episode and discuss spoilers from
the previous episode so see how that works
and then after couple episodes that I can
always course correct if I think there's a
better way to do it be that let me know in
the comments like what do you want to see
Supergirl do in season one I'm really curious
to see what they do with the Hank Henshaw
character just because Harrison wells was
so much fun on the flash but he turned out
to be an evil character in Hank Henshaw is
cyborg Superman in the comics so that they
just have to do something with that it is
certain point but it's gonna be a lot of fun
inlet like as they just kind of prime yourself
if you have a wash them in a while rewatch
the first to Christopher Reeves Superman films
and big shout out to this week's reverse flash
ring giveaway winner and congratulations to
them at the just private message me on the
back and my channels and get your contact
info normally the reverse flash ring giveaway
this would just be discussed in the the flash
and arrow videos but if I know my schedules
chainsaw all let you guys know from and announce
winners her or do anything related to that
in my Supergirl videos mostly as a private
figured out that that I do like schedule updates
at the end of videos so like is is long as
you pay attention to what what I'm talking
about when videos are coming at the end of
each video then you have a pretty good idea
of like the next couple of videos that I'm
working on select next for instance I'll be
doing a flash and arrow trailer will probably
due to separate videos just because the Constantine
stuff on arrow is like all the whole big different
thing so get have for that get paid for Supergirl
being that shipped out of a lot of people
that's gonna be so much fun so white as way
for that stuff to post you can click here
for my arrow episode from last night and you
can click here for my Supergirl playlist full
of videos and then said that thank you so
much for watching, everybody high five and
I'll see you guys tonight!